As an amateur
photographer, I wanted
to find out when is the
sun going to rise or set
at a particular landmark.
My name's Adam Ratana.
My day job, I work
for a large insurance
company as a software lead.
And in my spare time I
developed an Android and iOS
app called Sun Surveyor for
helping predict and visualize
positions of the sun and
moon, which has applications
in photography, architecture,
real estate, earth
science, and any other
use you can think of.
I used the Google Maps
APIs for Android and iOS.
And that's been
incredibly easy to use.
The maps experience
has changed over time.
People are used to now being
able to zoom in and tilt
and rotate maps and be able
to have a lot of overlays
and a lot of
interactive elements.
And so they've given
that to us as developers
to integrate in
our own apps, which
is an improvement
over the other APIs.
If a photographer wants to get
a picture of the sun crowning
the top half Half Dome using
Google Time Zone API and Google
Elevation API, I
can provide them
with the information they
need to plan it correctly.
What users of the
app really love
is the map and now
with Street View.
The Street View API is a
pretty big game changer
in that it lets you bring
a really powerful visual
of a remote location
right into an app
and really lets you
visualize the sun and moon
paths somewhere where you may
not be for weeks or months.
It's gone way beyond what I
imagined I could use it for.
It's pretty delightful.
It's pretty unexpected.
[MUSIC PLAYING]